hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Game of Thrones episode 3
video so so many W tips we have to talk
about I think we got a good picture for
where most of the action is going this
season so just careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet and new
round of the giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so here we go
starting with number 5 aria learns about
the inner workings of the house of black
and white including that she needs to
leave her life as Arya Stark behind it
was really heartbreaking to see her hide
needle I think we can all expect that by
the end of the season she'll probably go
searching for that again
the whole idea behind what jaqen is
trying to tell her is that she has to
leave her previous identity behind
she can't be Arya Stark any more she has
to be no one so this will be her new
costume for the next couple of episodes
she'll go through a couple costume
changes this season they already showed
off what her new costumes gonna look
like in the promo images it actually
looks pretty cool
who must recognize Faye marsay from the
Doctor Who Christmas special - as the
wait that's who she's playing the game
of faces looks an awful lot like a slap
fight that's just where they practice
shifting faces the idea is is that once
arya gets good enough she can just shift
faces at will but that's like years and
years of training away when jaqen was
talking to her in the temple about there
being one god a girl knows his name she
was talking about the many-faced God and
his gift his gift is the release from
the burden of life the gift of death
basically that man that she saw taking
the cup of water who said Valar
morghulis he was actually coming there
to die he was the same man that they
were embalming at the end of the episode
I don't want to get too crazy into
spoilers there they're like several
levels in the house of black and white
as you go lower it gets cooler trust me
in the next couple of episodes we'll
probably go down to the next level will
you find out exactly what happens to
those bodies once they're done with them
moving on to number 4 Brienne agrees to
Train Podrick as a knight she says that
she can't Knight him but that's only
because she's not a knight herself a
lord or a king otherwise she could have
done it on the spot she could have just
made him a knight it's really touching
to listen to them explain their
backstories - Brienne explains the story
about how Renly was really nice to her
when the sons of other Nobles were being
mean to her as a child her father wanted
to marry her off so so he created this
ball and invited a bunch of Lords with
their sons but they all just made fun of
her the whole time except for Wren
Podrick on the other hand is a pain so
so he has close ties with the Lannister
family so Tywin spared him whenever his
former night that he was squired to was
killed the twist is is that Brienne
feels that being squired to Tyrion is a
form of punishment
even though Podrick is consistently the
most positive character on the show
which means that he is probably not long
for the world usually the happier
characters are the ones with the big
targets on their backs moving at number
three Cersei meets with the high Sparrow
and agrees to reinstate the faith
militant if you didn't see it I actually
did a video last year all about the high
Sparrow who he is and who the faith
milta are they're basically the army of
the church they wear rainbow cloaks I'm
hoping they actually do them on the show
for right now they're just teeing the
sparrows up as the faith militant that
the people running around dealing with
immorality as they see it like the ones
that grab the former High Septon who is
now residing the black cells according
to Cersei it's a big departure from the
books in the books the old High Septon
the one that we saw in Littlefinger's
whorehouse was already dead in the
church actually voted the high Sparrow
up as the new High Septon internally
like the same way the Nights Watch votes
on their next Lord Commander he isn't
appointed by an outside body usually
it's the crown that appoints the High
Septon but in the case of the high
Sparrow in the books it's the church
itself you can see how the show is just
simplifying things they said Lancel in
the sparrows up as the future faith
militant characters the ones that are
gonna run around King's Landing knocking
heads who else thinks that Sparrow
Lancel is just like 10 times more badass
than season one Lancel Jonathan Pryce is
going to be so much fun on Game of
Thrones this season he's such a great
actor you you get a sense for why they
chose him he's very subtle but you get
the idea that he is wielding much more
power than he lets on when he's talking
to Cersei moving on to number two Jon
Snow beheads Janos Slynt this is just
like when Robb Stark beheaded Lord
Karstark so this also could have some
negative connotations in the future for
now though it seems like most the people
in the courtyard or at least the people
in positions of power agreed with what
he did the problem with that though is
is that yeah Stannis is happy with what
John did he believes in John but he's
taking his army and leaving that's with
his meeting with John is all about they
don't have enough food there to feed
that giant army or the wildlings
so Stannis is going to head south to
deal with the Bolton's and I believe
that they're teeing up the hardhome
story
where John leads an expedition to try
and get more wildlings sir Davos was
kind of trying to slap him in the face a
little bit just telling him that he
needed to get off his ass and go out and
do something so I think that's what
hardhome is going to be and as he said
tormund Giantsbane is going to be like
the stand-in new leader for Mance Rayder
and finally my number one WTF moment
Littlefinger is going to marry Sansa to
Ramsay Bolton and what we can just call
the gray wedding two more weddings this
season although the term and Margaery
wedding just kind of blew right by I'm
gonna go ahead and guess they skip the
wedding feast somehow I don't think that
there were any dwarves re-enacting the
war the five kings Sansa and Ramsay
though you know red flashing warning
lights going on all over the place so
they just said that it's going to happen
there has been no actual wedding yet we
have no idea whether or not this will
come to pass or if some big WTF is going
to derail it Sansa is gonna be on our
own - because Littlefinger was called
back to King's Landing and as you can
see Ramsay's partner in crime here she
is not really happy with the idea of
Sansa this is really taking the place of
the the fake Arya plot that goes on at
Winterfell
so it'll be really to see like how they
diverge or if they hit some of the same
beats so as we go along I'll try to talk
a little bit about how it's different
from the books and what about reaker who
just trying to avoid all side of Sansa
she will probably flip her ship when she
finds out that he's there it's kind of
heartbreaking watching him look around
kind of remember what he did to
Winterfell as the Bolton's were
rebuilding it if you're confused about
why Littlefinger wants Sansa to marry
Ramsay it's because he wants to form an
alliance between the Eyrie in the north
and go against the Lannisters goat you
know marjan King's Landing Littlefinger
controls the Eyrie as of right now even
though his hold on it's kind of tenuous
at best Roose Bolton controls the north
and he's kind of in a similar situation
he has like very tenuous control of the
north by rolling Sansa out there just
there hoping that it'll calm people up
in the north down then if they can do
that then they can secure the support
from the Lords of the Vale so this is
just like a daisy chain of problems
waiting to happen
so a couple other plots we have to
address starting with Tyrion in volantis
right off the bat one of the most
awesome cityscapes that they've done in
a while it's like the first time they
showed off marine that is big sweeping
CG cityscape tyrion gets captured by
Jorah Mormont who's going to take him to
Daenerys hoping to curry favor with her
this is straight out
the books that's the way it happens in
the books where they are though in dance
with dragons Tyrion hasn't made it to
Daenerys yet so this is where we're
gonna surge past the books in Tyrion
storyline this season
let me have Margaery and Tommen wedding
there there are a lot of people I've
seen who are wondering whether or not
Margaery might be a lesbian because she
does not seem into having sex with men
at all I don't think that's the case I
think that she just doesn't care like
she's just not overly excited about the
thought of sex with a young boy like
Tommen there was that shot last week
where she was staring at Oliver's but as
he got out of bed with Loras so she is
very clearly interested in the male form
it's just that I think that she's using
sex more as a tool just like Cersei uses
sex she just like Cersei is playing the
game of Thrones Cersei thinks that she's
won you know she's Queen Regent she's
getting rid of the small Council
Margaery is on the rise now that she and
Tommen are married she is Queen proper
she is the queen even though Cersei is
still calling herself Queen Regent as
for Brienne and Podrick you know one
really awesome bit of foreshadowing that
the brain was talking about when she
explained you know shadow with the face
of Stannis Baratheon is that I think
she's going to just try and kill Stannis
straight up
remember Stannis is marching south and
Brienne is marching north so what I'm
hoping to see is like you know like just
an all-out fight between Brienne and
Stannis then we have the mountain on chi
burns table here shaking very clearly
coming back to life this is also right
out of the books we're just at the
beginning of that plotline so if you
have read the books please use spoiler
tags but there's going to be some really
fun stuff happening with this we don't
get a whole lot of Qyburn seen so they
might have to gloss over a lot of this
if they do like whenever we see it in
episodes I'll try to explain how it goes
down in the books as they make changes
so here's my big question for you guys
Sansa and Ramsay you know how do you
think that that's going to go down will
they actually go through with the
marriage and do you think that Sansa is
going to end up killing Ramsay that to
me would be the most amazing outcome
Sansa someone who you typically would
think of it as being really weak taking
down one of the worst villains on the
show right now the other option would be
for reek to kill Ramsay to save Sansa
that would also be something of a
redemption for him I don't expect any
kind of like Sansa Ramsay confrontation
to go down for several episodes so we're
a ways away from that despite diverging
from the books and a huge way with this
you know Sansa Ramsay wedding I feel
like the episode delivered on some
really good WTF moments right now just
in terms of episodes this season I would
say it's tied for my favorite so far
with last week's episode just because
we're actually getting into the action
of the season things are actually
happening generally you know to a point
they do a good job of building the
tension building the action every single
week so just a reminder new round of the
giveaway all announced who the winner is
in my Q&A video tomorrow if you want to
follow me on Twitter and Facebook for
updates there are links at the bottom of
the description so if you haven't seen
it yet my bonus video from today was
just the history of Winterfell you can
click here to learn all about that and
you can click here for last week's
episode thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow
[Music]
you